peral bill morneau ministre fédéral des
finances est notre invité ce soir
bonsoir monsieur morneau et bonsoir
est ce que vous considérez que l'impact
du coronavirus sur l'économie canadienne
pourrait être très important c'est en ce
moment c'est difficile à dire exactement
l'impact c'est clair mais ce que je peux
dire est que c'est c'est clair qu'il y a
un impact sur les gens ah c'est clair
qu'il y a des impacts sur quelques
secteurs de notre économie de sa cure
comme vous avez dit tourisme par exemple
facture d'énergie et ce que nous voulons
faire et assurer les canadiens et les
canadiennes y compris les québécois et
les québécoises que c'est cesser le
mouvement fédéral qui va leur ai dit oui
on a la possibilité de faire des choses
pour pour l'économie et pour et pour les
accompagner et pour les gens qui va
améliorer la situation et comme quoi par
exemple qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire
concrètement pour aider les gens et de
les entreprises
qu'est ce qui est possible de faire au
début c'est nécessaire de commencer avec
les précautions pour notre système de
santé
ça veut dire que nous devons assurer que
nous avons assez des réseaus pourra pour
assurer que le système fonctionne
viennent c'est un système qui est
vraiment dans une bonne position pour
qu'ils ne serez notre défi mais on doit
assurer qu'il y assez deir ezzor est de
cette façon on peut protéger à nos
citoyennes ça c'est ça c'est au début
c'est très important
bien sûr après ça on nous n'avons que
cédric comment nous pouvons assurer les
gens qui qui ont peut-être le
possibilité d'être chez eux à cause
d'une quarantaine
chez eux à cause d'une heure une défis
spécifiques que on va avoir une
possibilité d'assurer qu'on a il on a
haché assez de réserves pour rentrer
chez eux et finalement pour les
compagnies il c'est clair qu'il ya une
une problème promet qu'avec les chaînes
de production de prothèses non c'est
nécessaire de considérer ça et en même
temps le problème de demande et on doit
avoir une approche qui va assurer la
compagne et qui va avoir assez de crédit
s'il ya un problème dans sa vie et les
mesures qui sont importants oui ça vous
en train de considérer exactement
comment nous pouvons à faire des choses
mais ce sera rude gérer les faits ce
sera dans dans le budget monsieur
morneau doit nécessairement pas
nécessairement d'accord on doit
considérer les faits donc à maintenant
on a déjà les défis pour les gens s'il
ya quelqu'un qui est en cantine par
exemple il a déjà des défis pour pour
quelques secteurs donc on va considérer
les choses
à quand les faits sont clairs et ça ça
veut dire que peut-être on a des choses
à dire en avant qu'une budget dans le
budget peut être on va avoir des autres
choses mais on doit toujours être
prudent
au niveau fiscal pour assurer que nous
nous protéger notre bon position nous
avons une très bonne session au niveau
fiscal par par les autres les en même
temps en même temps monsieur borno vous
avez des déficits importants
vous avez prévu aussi les difficiles de
20 à 30 milliards de dollars c'est déjà
prévu ce est ce que vous avez de la
marge de manoeuvre pour intervenir pour
aider l'économie surtout s'il ya un
ralentissement économique important
on commence avec notre situation par
rapport et les autres pays
donc c'est vrai qu'on a un déficit mais
c'est une tactique qui diminue chaque
année
c'est vrai qu'on a un niveau de dette
mais on a un niveau de dette qui diminua
par rapport à notre économie chaque
année notre situation est le meilleur
dans le g7
par rapport à notre économie est le plus
bas et de cette façon on a un bilan
fiscal qui est très bon on peut faire
des choses si les choses sont
nécessaires donc à haut débit pour les
gens pour les compagnies qui ont des
défis on apprécie les un problème pour
l'économie
on apprend qu'un problème s'il est un
problème on a le puissant
on n'a pas encore un problème dit vous
la banque du canada a baissé ses taux
d'intérêt de façon importante mais vous
considérer qu'on n'a pas encore un
problème économique
ce que ce que nous avons maintenant nous
avons un niveau de chômage qui est très
bas les salaires continuent d'être en
hausse
ça c'est très important c'est qu'une
bonne position c'est ce que je voudrais
dire c'est une bonne position maintenant
pour considérer l'avenir donc c'est ça
avec une position fiscale qui est aussi
dans une bonne position
une système de santé qui est qui est
bien à bien sortir et donc ça c'est une
autre question maintenant et si on a les
faits qui nous donne sens que c'est
nécessaire de faire quelque chose on
peut faire des choses est ce que vous
croyez qu'une récession est possible au
canada
ce que je voudrais dire à je peux pas
vous dire exactement notre situation ça
ça dépend le dur et le sévérité de la
couronne varicelle et le niveau de deux
longueurs au niveau géographique donc je
peux pas dire l'avenir exactement mais
je peux dire que nous avons les les
opportunités de faire quelque chose de
faire quelque chose de me lire et la
situation et ça c'est une bonne position
a bien sûr le banque du canada est déjà
fait quelque chose à nous devons
considérer les mesures fiscales parce
qu'il n'y a pas encore eu la possibilité
pour les banques de faire assez de
choses c'est vraiment pour les mesures
fiscales de considérer l'avenir
quand prévoyez vous présentez votre
budget nous nous sommes en train de
considérer les mesures pour le budget en
ce moment dans les prochaines semaines
au vert voire date exacte mais je dois
être sûr tant qu on a considéré notre
situation actuelle et les mesures qui
peut être là a immédiatement et les
mesures qui peut être là si on a un
problème plus grave mais je veux te dire
on n'a pas encore un problème qui est
aussi grave que les autres pays
donc on doit voir les mesures à la si
c'est nécessaire mais c'est une
association considérer les faits et s'il
ya une situation on va être prêt merci
beaucoup monsieur morneau merci